Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Drei Spieltage sind jetzt vergangen. Seit dem letzten Zweitliga-Kurzpass höchste Zeit wieder draufzuschauen. Hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 185. Und zudem begrüße ich euch ganz herzlich. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Edgenetzer auf Twitter. Und wie es inzwischen, ja ich würde sagen, jetzt schon eine Tradition ist, habe ich wieder zwei Gäste hier. Ich begrüße, es ist so schön, diese Stimmen wieder zu hören. Es sind so, also die Leute, die schon länger beim Rasenfunk mit dabei sind, die werden beide Gäste wiedererkennen. Zum einen Matthias Kneifl. Ihr kennt ihn vom Hoch- und Weitpodcast. Ihr kennt ihn als Autor des Kick-Schuh-Blogs und auch als Autor unter anderem des Buches 111 Gründe, den SV Darmstadt 98 zu lieben. Und vielleicht habt ihr jetzt auch erraten, was einer der Schwerpunktvereine dieser Folge sein wird. Hallo Matthias. Ja, es ist sehr schön, dich mal wieder mit dabei zu haben. Ich hab jetzt gar nicht mehr nachgeguckt, wann du das letzte Mal hier warst.
Das müsste 2016 zu Erstliga-Zeiten gewesen sein.
Jetzt muss ich doch nachgucken. Also jetzt hast du mich herausgefordert. Das muss ich unbedingt überprüfen. Das wären ja 5 Jahre. 2017, im Juni 2017 warst du das letzte Mal hier. Ich hab hier noch deinen alten Twitter-Handel. Also das sind wirklich lange Zeiten. Und ich werde sofort mal nachgucken, wann wir das letzte Mal Florian Zenger hier hatten. Das war 2019 der Fall. Zum zweiten Mal hier. Hallo Flo von den Clubfans United. Bei der Nürnberger Zeitung kann man ihn lesen. Im Clubpodcast Kadeb kann man ihn hören. Auf Twitter kann man ihm folgen als etflo-zenger. Hallo Flo.
Servus, danke für die Einladung.
Es wurde mal wieder allehöchste Zeit, würde ich sagen. Wir wollen über die 2. Bundesliga sprechen. Wie wir das bisher so in den Kurzpässen gemacht haben, haben wir uns fast die Hälfte der Liga vorgenommen. Und wir schauen ein bisschen, dass alle Vereine drankommen im Laufe der Folgen. Heute wollen wir über acht Vereine sprechen. Ich entschuldige mich jetzt schon bei all diejenigen, die Fans von Vereinen sind, die jetzt nicht vorkommen. Ich werde versuchen, dass die dann in den nächsten Ausgaben mal dran kommen. Wir gehen die Tabelle von unten nach oben durch. Und Flo, du hattest als Idee, über die Aufsteiger zu sprechen und die mal ein bisschen in Vergleich zu setzen. Und da müssen wir, wenn wir unten beginnen, beim FC Ingolstadt 04 anfangen. Denn der ist Tabellen-18. Nach elf Spieltagen hat fünf Punkte, erst einmal gewonnen und erst sieben Tore nach elf Spielen erzielt. Ist das Teil des Problems von Ingolstadt? Rhetorische Frage.
Das ist eines der größten Probleme in Ingolstadt, dass die sich sehr, sehr schwer tun, nach vorne was zu bringen. Sie sind ja dann so ein bisschen aufgestiegen, noch so mit Stefan Kutschke als Aggressiv-Leader vorne drin, als jemand, der dann auch mal für den Kopfball und so weiter gut ist. Und Kutschke ist jetzt erst eine Zeit lang ausgefallen und der kommt halt auch so langsam in ein Alter, wo man sagt, na ja, da ist für einen Stürmer vielleicht jetzt irgendwann dann mal Schluss und das ist schon einer der Gründe, warum es nicht so läuft. Zum anderen sind sie auch ganz furchtbar in der ersten Halbzeit. Vor der Pause haben sie, glaube ich, erst ein Tor erzielt, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe.
Also in der ersten Halbzeit nicht so viel zu erwarten beim FC Ingolstadt, das ist wirklich sehr wenig. Matthias, wie siehst du die bisherige Saison der Ingolstädter? Dass sie jetzt nicht hier brillieren, ist jetzt nicht auch komplett überraschend?
Ne, also ich habe es noch vor Augen, als sie in Darmstadt gastierten, da war Darmstadt auch noch ziemlich in schwerem Fahrwasser gefangen und dann hat Darmstadt auch mit 6 zu 1 deutlich die Oberhand behalten, seinerzeit noch an der Seitenlinie Roberto Petzold. Da war schon einiges nicht so griffig und schlüssig, also dass sich ein Aufsteiger dann auswärts mal so überfahren lässt, ist jetzt nicht unbedingt außergewöhnlich, aber hat mich dann in der Deutlichkeit auch überrascht. Und jetzt hatten sie natürlich zuletzt auch so ein 6-Punktespiel, wie man so schön sagt, in Aue, das sie dann auch verloren haben, zum Schluss noch den Pfosten getroffen haben, aber da geht im Moment einfach ganz wenig auf. Also du hast die Parameter ja schon benannt. Ansonsten glaube ich, kann Floda noch ein bisschen was dazu ausführen, aber ich meine, sie hatten vor der Saison ausgegeben, dass sie eher versuchen, auch mit der Personalier Petzold auf dem Trainersessel eher auf junge Spieler zu setzen, die durchaus auch so ein bisschen aus der Umgebung kommen oder aus dem eigenen Unterbau. Und als dann der Saisonstart so ein bisschen schon in die Hose ging, haben sie ja noch mal ordentlich nachgelegt auf dem Transfermarkt. Und das geht im Moment aber auch noch nicht so richtig auf. Und sie haben, meine ich, auch einige Verletzte, das ihnen natürlich auch nicht so richtig zum Vorteil gereicht. Und wen ich aus eigenem Erleben auch noch kenne, ist der Innenverteidiger aus Dänemark. Ich meine, Paulsen hieß er. Der dürfte denen auch fehlen. Der ist nach Schweden gegangen und ich glaube, der war schon auch ein stabilisierender Faktor in der Elf. Also mit anderen Worten, sie sind aufgestiegen mit anderem Manager, mit anderem Trainer, haben dann im Sommer einiges auf links gebügelt, kommen aber nach wie vor nicht so richtig aus den Pötten. Das ist leider so zu konstatieren aus Ingolstädter Sicht.
Ja, also um das zu betonen, also ich habe mir mal rausgesucht, wie jetzt so die Altersverteilung bei denen ist. In Ingolstadt ist es so, also knapp 35 Prozent der Einsatzminuten gehen auf Spieler unter 23. Wenn man es auf unter 21 rechnet, sind es knapp 20 Prozent. Also es sind wirklich junge Spieler. Und auch der Punkt, den du anführst, mit denen aus der Region, also Ingolstadt ist der Verein mit dem höchsten Anteil an Local Players in den Einsatzminuten. Das ist ungefähr ein Viertel der Minuten. Es fällt auf Spieler, die unter diese Local-Player-Regelung fallen. Man sieht da schon das ganze Konzept, das dahinter ist. Es sind auch relativ wenig Neuzugänge, die auf Minuten kommen. Also auch da der Anteil ist relativ gering. Und da merkt man dann schon, sie setzen auf die Spieler, die eh schon da waren. Und die waren letztes Jahr noch Drittligaspieler. Und ich kann mich auch erinnern, dass der angesprochene Stefan Kuczki nach ein paar Spieltagen schon gemeint hat, ja, wir müssen nochmal zuschlagen. Das ist dann auch irgendwie passiert. Aber das ist natürlich dann so ein bisschen Operation am offenen Herzen, wenn die Saison schon angefangen hat. Und dann hat man eben auch noch einen Trainer ausgetauscht. Und dann ist es natürlich ganz, ganz schwierig da reinzukommen.
Mit einem bekannten Namen. Andre Schubert ist jetzt Trainer beim FC Ingolstadt. Ende September war das der Fall dieser Wechsel. Das Petzold entlassen wurde. Auch der sportliche Leiter Florian Zehe wurde freigestehlt. Jetzt haben wir jetzt Ende Oktober. Das heißt, rund einen Monat konnte man ihn im Amt erleben. Matthias, traust du dir eine Einschätzung zu? Hat sich was verändert?
Traue ich mir tatsächlich schwer, das zu beantworten. Aber was, glaube ich, sich wenig geändert hat, ist tendenziell dennoch, dass in diversen Parametern in der Tabelle unten drin hängen. Also nicht nur jetzt mit den Punkten, die auf dem grünen Rasen zu erzielen waren, sondern auch, was zum Beispiel das Passspiel anbetrifft oder auch einfach die Tore aus einem Spiel heraus. Da tut sich einfach ganz, ganz wenig. Fünf Stück nur bei sieben erzielten Toren. Das ist jetzt auch nicht weiter verwunderlich, aber da scheint es ja doch einfach an dem Konzept zu mangeln, wie man in sehr gute Abschlusssituationen kommt. Und wenn jetzt auch am Wochenende sich noch mit Eckart Ayensa, für meine Begriffe, ein wichtiger Spieler, mit einem Schlüsselbeinbruch verabschiedet, dann heißt es erstmal nichts Gutes. Also ich denke, das sind viele, viele Zeichen, die mit dem bestehenden Personal jetzt glaube ich erst mal ein ziemlich gehöriger Kraftakt erfordern, da was ins Positive zu verkehren. Also er kann ja jetzt auch die Transferpolitik, die vor seiner Zeit getätigt war, nicht umkehren. Deshalb wird schon ein ordentliches Brett, das er dazu geboren hat.
Und das, obwohl es dieses Testspiel gab von Ingolstadt mit 7 zu 0. 7 zu 0 beim 1. FC Nürnberg geworden. Was war da los?
Was war da los, ja. Das Spiel hat natürlich, Robert Klaus, der Nürnberger Trainer, sagt er dann, wenn man ihn drauf anspricht, das Spiel hat eine Geschichte und das hat natürlich eine Geschichte. Es ging schon so los, dass Ingolstadt halt im Spiel war. Die Spieler wollten sich wahrscheinlich Andrej Schubert auch zeigen. Und das Spiel war vormittags um 11. Und man hatte so ein bisschen das Gefühl, die Club-Spieler waren so der Meinung, na ja, jetzt müssen wir halt da raus und ein bisschen kicken. Und das war von der Einstellung her tatsächlich, also ich spreche ungern von Einstellungen im Fußball, weil ich das für ein etwas ausgelutschtes Topos halte und das auch ein bisschen übertrieben finde. Aber in dem Fall stimmt es schon. Also man war halt einfach nicht völlig da. Und dann läuft das Spiel so vor sich hin und dann steht es 3-0. Und dann gibt es eine rote Karte, also in einem Testspiel, weil Fabian Nürnberger einfach jemanden die Beine wegzieht, der ihm gerade einen Ball abgenommen hat, also voll reinhaut, völlig zurecht auch, hat dann eher noch Glück, dass er nicht für den normalen Liga-Betrieb gesperrt wird. Und dann spielst du halt auch noch eine Halbzeit lang mit 10 Mann. Und dann, ja, also es darf trotzdem natürlich nicht 7-0 ausgehen. Aber in der zweiten Halbzeit war dann auch noch, sagen wir mal vom Personal her, dann waren auch zwei um 19 Spieler noch mit drin und so weiter.
Ich sehe schon, es federt das ganz gut ab. Also Ingolstadt-Tabellen, Platz 18. Ich glaube, wir haben es ganz gut einsortiert. Dann schauen wir mal auf Hansa Rostock, den zweiten der drei Aufsteige. Für die läuft es deutlich besser. 6 Punkte mehr als die Ingolstädter. Das heißt, 11 Punkte sind das jetzt nach 11 Spieltagen. Eine durchwachsene Bilanz, seitdem wir den letzten Kurzpass aufgenommen haben. Also gegen Kiel gewonnen auswärts, dann zu Hause unentschieden gegen St. Hausen. Jetzt dann ein deutliches 0 zu 4 beim FC St. Pauli. Matthias, wie gefallen dir denn die Rostocker?
Also gegen St. Pauli haben sie sogar ganz gefällig begonnen. Also der Zauber war dann zwar nach 10 Minuten oder einer Viertelstunde dahin, aber auch das hat mich so ein bisschen an das Spiel von Darmstadt in Rostock seinerzeit erinnert. Also insbesondere der Omladić ist ein ziemlich gefährlicher oder wuseliger Angreifer, der auch mit dem Ball einiges auf dem Kasten hat. Der hat ja auch diese Szene heraufbeschworen, die dann noch entschärft wurde, schlussendlich. Aber gegen St. Pauli war dann natürlich schnell irgendwie die Messe gesungen und das liegt natürlich, da werden wir nachher noch drauf eingehen, primär an St. Pauli, finde ich, weil Rostock sich bislang ja auswärts sogar einigermaßen gut präsentiert, zumindest was die Puntausbeute anbetrifft. Da hingegen zuhause eher anfällig, der einzige Sieg ausgerechnet gegen Darmstadt. Und da dachte ich, dass das heimische Stadion so eine verlässliche Base wird für den Club, weil auch die Leute, die ich kenne, die da waren, sagten, dass es schon eine sehr beeindruckende Stimmung war, also ziemlich laut und die Darmstädter Mannschaft war vielleicht auch für einen Moment eher irritiert, was da so abgeht, aber ich glaube, sie müssen auf schon daheim setzen, dass da noch mehr geht, dass da die Punkte runterfallen und ich glaube, sie haben auch einen sehr guten Coach, dem ich zutraue, dass er das Optimum aus der Truppe rausholt mit Jens Härtel, der jetzt auch schon bald drei Jahre, mein ich, in Rostock ist und davor lange Jahre in Magdeburg erfolgreich dann auch gearbeitet hat. Also ich finde, da stimmen schon ein paar Parameter mehr, als jetzt in Ingolstadt, für meinen Begriff.
Ja, also Jens Härtel finde ich auch einen guten Punkt, weil er also einer der Zweitligatrainer ist, der relativ adaptiv spielt, also der sich mehr auf den Gegner einstellt als andere Trainer, sondern dann immer mal wieder darauf reagiert und das auch mit ziemlich guten Maßnahmen, also dann auch mal die Grundformation wechselt, je nachdem, wie es passt für den jeweiligen Gegner. Die Truppe an sich hat für mich ein bisschen ein Problem, dass er einfach noch zu viele gute Chancen zulässt. Also wenn man sich mal die Statistik anschaut, so die Expected Goals pro Schuss, da ist, also des Gegners, da ist Rostock auf quasi auf dem letzten Platz mit 0,15 XG pro gegnerischem Schuss, da kann man sicherlich noch dran arbeiten, weil das erklärt dann auch so ein bisschen die Anzahl der Gegentore, die ja doch relativ hoch ist mit mit 19 und da müssen sie ein bisschen dran arbeiten. Ich finde sie aber, also gerade angesprochene Omladesch, der hat auch noch eine andere Qualität mit seinen Standards. Also ich kann mich an das Spiel in Nürnberg erinnern, wo wirklich eigentlich fast jeder seiner Standards gefährlich war. Und das sind schon so Punkte, wo ich sage, das funktioniert schon wesentlich besser. Sie haben auch, finde ich, von der Balance zwischen Drittligaspielern und jetzt neu zu gängen. Ich denke da natürlich als Nürnberger an Hannu Behrens, der da durchaus eine wichtige Rolle jetzt übernommen gleich hat. Also da ist die Balance ganz gut gefallen. Und insgesamt, ja, also ich denke, sie haben eben mit dem Trainer ein Pfund, das vielleicht andere Mannschaften nicht haben.
Also das, was du gerade meintest, Flo, stimmt schon. Also ich müsste mich jetzt auch noch mal zurückbesinnen, um Ladic hat damals tatsächlich die beiden Tore von Rostock gegen Darmstadt per Standard vorgelegt, war aber auch im Spiel einfach ein ständiger Unruheherd und worauf sie dennoch mehr achten müssen ist meines Erachtens dann vorne die Chancen, die du schon erwähnt hast, dann auch zu verwerten, weil da ist im Moment verhockt in einem unguten, wie soll man sagen, also das ist nicht sehr austariert, die Leute, die die Tore schießen, da hat er mit sechs von elf Toren ein deutliches Übergewicht und da scheint mir eine gewisse Abhängigkeit für den Moment da zu sein. Das müssten sie schon in den Griff kriegen, sonst wird es vielleicht doch wieder nach hinten raus nicht so angenehm.
Aktuell sieht es ja noch ganz gut aus bei der Hansa, bei der Kocke und vielleicht kriegt man ja dann auch die Heimstärke irgendwann auf den Rasen. Bleibt noch Dynamo Dresden, die aktuell einen Platz vor Hansa liegen, allerdings zwei Punkte mehr haben. 13 Punkte hat Dresden, obwohl Flo die letzten drei Spiele alles andere als erfolgreich verlaufen sind. Die hat man alle drei verloren. Man könnte allerdings jetzt auch sehr richtigerweise anführen, auch gegen Gegner eines anderen Kaliber. Also jetzt zuletzt auf Schalke 0 zu 3 verloren, dann gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg zu Hause mit 0 zu 1 verloren und gegen St. Pauli mit 0 zu 3 verloren. Das waren jetzt natürlich auch alles Gegner aus dem oberen Tabellendrittel. Wie gefällt dir denn das, was Dresden macht?
Die sind von der Herangehensweise halt ein bisschen anders. Also die sind so, dass sie sagen, ja, also es ist uns relativ egal, wenn man einen Ball halt auch mal verlieren. Wir wollen schnell nach vorne gehen und das sieht man halt dann auch. Also viele Ballverluste, aber eben auch viele dann Balleroberungen relativ früh. Also Alexander Schmidt spielt da durchaus ein System, wo ich sage, das ist zumindest ambitioniert, aber man erkennt eine Handschrift und deshalb gefällt mir das eigentlich ganz gut. Ich mag das immer, wenn man zumindest sieht, was so die Idee ist und was die Mannschaft vorhat. Ich fand es auch gegen den Klub durchaus so, dass man sagt, ja das Spiel müssen sie nicht unbedingt verlieren.
Das Spiel jetzt am Wochenende gegen Schalke fand ich ganz ansehnlich, vor allem in der zweiten Hälfte. Da hätte durchaus der Ausgleich auch fallen können, wenn der Keeper von Schalke nicht so gut pariert hätte nach dem einen Standard. Deshalb sind sie da deutlich unter Wert geschlagen worden, für meinen Begriff. Ich glaube, zum Schluss war sogar auf Sky zu sehen, dass der Expat Goals Wert pro Dresden ausgeschlagen hätte bei dem Spiel, was bei einem 0 zu 3 eher merkwürdig erscheint.
Ja, sieben und drei Worte in der Gegnersmannschaft ist dann vielleicht eine Erklärung.
Das stimmt. Und zwar standards, klar. Aber im Endeffekt fand ich den Auftritt überraschend gut. Nichtsdestotrotz. Also da scheint es nach wie vor zu stimmen im Team. Du hast ja schon angemerkt, dass man jetzt drei andere Kaliber, auf die sie zuletzt getroffen waren. Und da gehe ich jetzt erst mal mit einem, klar für Dresden-Vans eher blöden Gefühl aus der Geschichte raus, aber ich fand das doch ein mutmachend, ein Auftritt. Jetzt sollen sie sich nur nicht entmutigen lassen, aber der gute Stadt hilft ihnen nach wie vor und ich glaube gegen die Mannschaften, gegen die sie zuletzt verloren haben, kann man verlieren. Also da würde ich jetzt nach wie vor sagen, alles drin.
Ist mit Abstand die offensiv stärkste Mannschaft der drei, die wir jetzt angeguckt haben? Das meine ich jetzt nicht nur wegen der Tore, die man mehr erzielt hat als die anderen beiden, sondern auch einfach, wenn man sich die Produktion der Schüsse anguckt, da liegt Dresden auf Platz 9 in der zweiten Liga, jetzt nur eben nach Schüssen. Rostock auf Platz 16, Ingolstadt auf Platz 17. Also da gibt es einen deutlichen Unterschied. Aber Flo, in der Defensive auch ein bisschen. Du hast vorhin schon die Expected Goals bei gegnerischen Schüssen angesprochen im Bereich der Rostocker. Bei Dresden scheint mir das auch noch so ein Thema zu sein, dass man offen hin nach beiden Seiten ist. Wenn du jetzt die drei Aufsteiger nebeneinander stellst, wo würdest du sagen, wessen Spielidee hat die größten Chancen in dieser zweiten Liga?
Ich würde tatsächlich, das ist schwierig, weil ich Dresden und Rostock relativ ähnlich sehe. Ich sehe bei Dresden insgesamt vielleicht ein bisschen ambitionierter, weil es ein bisschen weniger adaptiv ist, ein bisschen weniger auf den Gegner eingestellt ist und dann natürlich viel von den einzelnen Spielern abhängig ist. Ich denke da an Darferna bei Dresden und von daher an sich ja. Also Dresden hat natürlich auch so ein bisschen das Problem, das du auch ansprichst. Viele lassen viele Schüsse zu. Wer viele Schüsse zulässt, läuft halt immer Gefahr, dass einer reingeht, egal wie hoch der Expected Goals Wert des jeweiligen Schusses ist. Mehr Schüsse sind immer erstmal gefährlich und von daher ja. Also ich könnte mich schwer zwischen zwischen Dresden und Rostock entscheiden. Wenn ich es müsste, würde ich wahrscheinlich auf Dresden gehen, weil ich es ein bisschen klarer erkennbar finde und ich diese direkte Spielweise dann in der zweiten Liga oft für relativ Erfolg versprechend halte.
Also dieses schnell dann tief gehen. Deckt sich das mit deinen Eindrücken, Matthias?
Vielleicht kann man noch sagen, dass Dresden ja jetzt längst nicht so lange weg war vom Fenster wie Rostock. Für die ist der Aufstieg in die zweite Liga natürlich irgendwie wieder Neuland. Die waren ja doch einige Zeit in der dritten Liga gefangen und Dresden, wir erinnern uns, hatte ja seinerzeit diesen Corona-Abstieg, wenn ich es jetzt mal als er auf der Ziegeraden sehr viele Spiele in kurzer Zeit hatten. Und deshalb war das vielleicht eher eine Reparatur eines Unfalls, dieser Abstieg. Und den haben sie in einer Saison schnell hingekriegt, zwar auch mit einem Trainerwechsel. Aber vielleicht sind sie im Vergleich zu den anderen beiden, oder zumindest zu Rostock-Aufsteigern, dann doch noch mal in einer anderen Situation. Und deshalb traue ich ihnen auch unter den drei genannten ein Ticken mehr zu.
Beim Thema Abstieg können wir auch über Werder Bremen sprechen. Die liegen auf Tabellen Platz 10 in der 2. Liga, 15 Punkte. Das heißt, das sind 10 Punkte bis zu Platz 1, bzw. 27 zum Relegation, 7, Entschuldigung, bis zum Relegationsplatz. Und nach unten hin sind es 6 Punkte auf den Relegationsplatz. Das heißt, man hat sich in der Mitte positioniert. Und nachdem das ein Absteiger aus der 1. Liga ist, nachdem das auch, war das jetzt nur ein Unfall, das muss jetzt Werder Bremen beweisen, liegt da noch mal jetzt ein anderer Fokus bei den Bremern auf der bisherigen Saison. Man hat irgendwie so ein bisschen mit dem weitergemacht, was wir bisher auch so im Rasenfunk schon besprochen haben. Es geht fröhlich hin und her für Werder. 3 zu 0 gegen den FC Heidenheim gewonnen, 0 zu 3 in Darmstadt gespielt, Matthias. Deswegen, dass du auch gleich mal vorlegen. Jetzt dann 2 zu 2 in Sandhausen. Sehr, sehr spektakulär hinten raus noch. Also das war auch alles andere als klar mit dem Ausgleich von Niklas Völkruck erst in der 91. Minute. Du hast jetzt Werder gerade erst gesehen gegen Darmstadt. Wie würdest du da die Situation einschätzen?
Die ist mir durchaus vertraut, weil Markus Anfang ist für mich dann doch so der primäre Faktor, wenn es darum geht, Bremen zu beurteilen. Wir erinnern uns, letztes Jahr war er hier am Böllnfalltor am Start, ist dann gegangen, hat dem Ruf von Werder gefolgt oder ist ihm gefolgt und er ist halt ein Trainer, der den offensiven Spielansatz propagiert, der nicht sagt, ich will nicht verlieren, sondern wir wollen gewinnen und wir wollen nach vorne spielen und wir wollen proaktiv sein. Wir hatten es bei uns im Podcast seinerzeit, als wir noch nicht wussten, wie die Saison verlaufen würde, gesagt, das ist so ein lebensbejahender Ansatz. Manchmal ist es auch so ein leicht morbider Ansatz, weil die Mannschaft einfach, ich glaube, das ist in Bremen nach wie vor auch dasselbe, wie seinerzeit lange Zeit in Darmstadt, ihr fehlt die Balance. Also er hat es nicht verstanden, relativ rasch diese Disbalance in den Griff zu kriegen, sondern er denkt halt positiv, er will, dass hinten flach rausgespielt wird. Die Mannschaft soll die Fäden in der Hand behalten, aber oft entgleiten sie ihn und das sehe ich im Moment halt genauso in Bremen. Also ich frage mich auch, warum Bremen ihn wollte. Einerseits kann ich verstehen, er war ein Zweitligatrainer, hat unterm Strich gute Ergebnisse erzielt in Kiel, in Köln und in Darmstadt. Er kennt also das Umfeld, in dem Bremen sich jetzt unvermittelt wiederfindet, aber Bremen hat ja in der ersten Liga auch jetzt nicht unbedingt durch spielerische Ansätze geklenzt. Jetzt holen sie einen Trainer, der in der zweiten Liga auch spielerische Ansätze wertlegt in einer Liga, die zugegebenermaßen ja doch auch eine physische Komponente noch braucht und vor allem eine Bereitschaft im Kopf, sich diese Liga anzunehmen. Grüße nach Hamburg. Also es ist schon verwunderlich, warum sie auf ihn per se gesetzt hatten. Nach hinten raus kann es auch gut gehen, aber so wie sich die Situation im Moment darstellt, überrascht mich nicht, muss ich offen gestehen. Das ist einfach zu fehleranfällig, dieses Prinzip. Und die Mannschaft scheint es noch nicht so richtig veränderlich zu haben. Jetzt haben wir alle vor Augen, wie Lars Lukas May in Sandhausen agiert hat. Nicht sehr glücklich, aber erschien mir manchmal auch nicht konzentriert genug zu sein. Also verliert den Gegenspieler einfach aus den Augen, hört auf zu laufen, macht einen Rückpass auf einen Torwart, der eher handbüchen ist. Also da ist vieles noch nicht sehr im Lot. Ende meiner Ausführungen erst mal zu dem Punkt.
Flo, du bist ja jetzt ein langjähriger Beobachter der zweiten Liga. Glaubst du, ein solcher Ansatz kann zum Aufstieg führen?
Ich denke, wenn man die passenden Spieler dafür hat, dass man einfach individuell so viel drüber ist wie die anderen, dann kann das schon funktionieren. Ich denke jetzt zum Beispiel mal an den VfB Stuttgart, der ja auch erst mit Tim Walther und dann mit Pellegrino Matarazzo ja auch einen sehr, sehr spielerischen Ansatz hatte. Und auch die haben sich lange schwer getan. Die sind da auch nicht durchmarschiert. Und ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen das, was mein Bremen vielleicht auch unterschätzt hat. Jetzt kommt in Bremen halt noch dazu, dass die Mannschaft unglaublich jung ist. Also da sind wir bei fast 50 Prozent der Einsatzzeiten für unter oder für 23-Jährige oder Jünger. Und da bist du halt einfach auch an dem Punkt, dass die natürlich, solche Spieler, haben halt einfach noch mehr Schwankungen drin. Und gerade der Ansatz verzeiht ja eigentlich überhaupt keine Schwankungen.
Ich habe gelesen in einem Blogbeitrag, Markus Anfang sei der Pep Guardiola der zweiten Liga.
Den wollte ich auch noch bringen. Den habe ich auch gelesen, ja. Ich denke, das ist so ein bisschen auf den Ballbesitzansatz geschoben. Aber wenn man jetzt dann mal guckt, der HSV hat noch mal deutlich mehr Ballbesitz. Kiel ist da auch so in der Richtung, die in der Kategorie viel Ballbesitz haben. Ja, das schon. Aber ich finde, Guardiolas Mannschaften haben deutlich mehr Balance zwischen den Mannschaftsteilen und die spielen dann den Gegner so tot mit ihren Pässen. Und ich meine, da ist Bremen ja noch weit weg davon. Und waren auch seine anderen Mannschaften weit weg davon. Markus Anfang hat sie ja eigentlich immer dadurch ausgezeichnet, dass seine Mannschaften viel mehr Tore geschossen haben als kassiert. Aber sie haben ordentlich kassiert.
Wenn ich jetzt aber nur auf die Statistik gucke, dann ist Werder eine Mannschaft, die nicht nur viel den Ball hat, auch wenn da, also was da Hamburg macht, ist ja der Wahnsinn, 65 Prozent Ballbesitz im Durchschnitt. Aber Werder mit 60 auch sehr, sehr deutlich. Man ist aber auch die Mannschaft, in die die meisten Schüsse pro Spiel abgibt. Jetzt gucke ich aber halt nicht genügend Zweite Liga, um diese Statistik einordnen zu können. Matthias, welche Qualität jetzt dann diese Abschlüsse haben? Ist das auch ein Teil des Problems, dass man aus seinen Chancen zu wenig macht? Oder drückt mich da jetzt einfach die Statistik oder sind lauter Distanzschüsse?
Nee, ich habe auch die Statistik gestern mal bemüht. Also Bremen hat nach dem, was ich gesehen habe, sowohl außerhalb als auch innerhalb des Strafraums die meisten Schüsse abgegeben. Je weiter der Schuss weg ist, außer man heißt vielleicht Johannes Geist, dann wird es auch umso weniger vielversprechender ein Tor zu erzielen. Also ja, ich glaube, bei Bremen hat auch aus dem Spiel heraus nicht viel getroffen. Also in der Liste meines 8.12. sehe ich gerade mit 8 aus dem Spielhaus erzielten Toren. Das ist für eine Mannschaft eines Markus Anfang wenig, definitiv. Ich glaube, man hat sich jetzt auch so ein bisschen erhofft, dass Dux einfach zündet. Man war ja unter ihm in Kiel schon Torschützenkönig. Wir erinnern uns, in Köln und Darmstadt hat auch jeweils den Torschützenkönig gestellt, mit Horda und Ursun. Gut möglich, dass Dux auch jetzt wieder Torschützenkönig wird irgendwann. Aber es ist mir auf ein bisschen zu wenige Schlüsselspieler dann ausgerichtet. Was machen wir denn, wenn Dux irgendwann mal, es möge nicht eintreten, aber verletzten eine längere Zeit fehlt? Dann bin ich auch mal gespannt, was das bedeutet. Also ich finde sie haben klar den spielerischen Ansatz. Der überrascht nicht. Was dir nicht gefallen wird, Max, sie schlagen wohl auch die meisten Flanken. Das ist noch nicht so richtig eingeschwungen.
Von Winkl und Pep Guardiola der 2.
Ich glaube, die Mannschaft braucht einfach noch eine Weile, um das zu verinnerlichen, was Markus Anfang von ihnen will. Er hat auch in Darmstadt gesagt, er will einfach schön spielen, er will erfolgreich spielen, er will Spieler weiterentwickeln. Das war seine 3-Säulen-Theorie. Die braucht er aber. Ich sehe es in Bremen auch nicht als unmöglich an, dass die in die Spur kommen. Aber genauso wenig überrascht mich jetzt dieser Holper-Stadt.
Gut, wir als neutrale Beobachter können uns ja einfach angucken, was da noch bei Werder passieren würde. Definitiv gibt es was zu sehen bei Werder. Und das ist ja, wenn man sich an die letzten Erstliga-Jahre erinnert, dann durchaus vielleicht eine positive Nachricht. Selbst wenn das nicht zum Wiederaufstieg führen sollte, kann man sich Werder-Bremens-Spiele sehr gut ansehen. Dann wollen wir jetzt mal die Frage klären, wie gut man sich Spiele des SV Darmstadt 98 ansehen kann. Von den Ergebnissen her ließ sich das ja ganz gut. Fünf Siege, zwei Unentschieden, viele Niederlagen. Das ergibt 17 Punkte. Wir sprechen jetzt auch in einer Phase, Matthias, in der in den letzten drei Spielen zweimal gewonnen und einmal unentschieden gespielt werden konnte. Das heißt, trotz zum Beispiel des Trainerwechsels lässt sich es ja gut an bei Darmstadt und das, obwohl es so einige Fragen aufwirft. Das ist ja einer der Gründe, warum wir hier sprechen, weil im letzten Zweitliga-Kurzpass meine Gäste und logischerweise damit auch ich nicht so ganz erklären konnten, woher kommt das jetzt dann? Und dann gewinnt Darmstadt 6 zu 1 in Sandhausen und 3 zu 0 gegen Werder, spielt jetzt aber auch 1 zu 1 gegen Kiel. Was ist los bei euch?
Ich bin alles in allem zufrieden mit dem bisherigen Saisonverlauf. Also wir stehen besser da als in den gesamten Zweitliga-Spielzeiten der letzten Jahre, weil wir immer in Darmstadt so diesen Herbstfluch hatten, in dem wir regelmäßig nach hinten durchgereicht wurden, um dann in der Rückrunde glorreich aufzuholen. Deshalb sind wir dieses Jahr sehr gut unterwegs. Wir hatten ja Anfang der Saison die ersten zwei Spieltage unter erschwerten Bedingungen zu bestreiten. Also da gab es sehr viele Corona-bedingte Ausfallausfälle zu beklagen oder auch einfach Quarantänemaßnahmen. Deshalb hatten wir hier einfach einen sehr ausgedünnten Kader am Start und dennoch hat der Verein und in erster Linie Thorsten Lieberknecht die Situation angenommen. Also er hat nicht lamentiert. Er hat gesagt, hier aus so einer Situation kann auch was erwachsen. Wir machen jetzt hier einen Schulterschluss und das hört sich manchmal platt an. Aber ich glaube, die Ergebnisse zeigen, dass da durchaus auch die richtigen Schlüsse aus der Situation gezogen wurden. Die Mannschaft hat auch ein ziemlich anderes Gesicht im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr. Also 12 Neuzugänge, von denen viele sich tatsächlich schon etabliert haben. In erster Linie die Sturmspitze mit Tietz und mit Pfeiffer, also Luca Pfeiffer.
Jeweils acht Tore, das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Genau, insofern schon mal Dursuns Abgang kompensiert und das war in der Form sicherlich nicht zu erwarten. Wir hatten so eine gewisse Unsicherheit, wie sich die Saison darstellen wird. Ich hatte aber auch vor der Saison schon die Gelegenheit mit Thorsten Lieberknecht ein Interview zu führen und ich muss sagen, er hat einfach eine sehr authentische Art. Er ist nahbar, er ist nicht aufgesetzt, er ist kein Karrierist, glaube ich. Er ist jemand, der nicht wie Markus Anfang jetzt nach Bremen abwandern wird, weil er da irgendwie größere Ziele erreichen kann, sondern ich glaube, er verschreibt sich einfach mit dem Verein. Eine kleine. Also er verschreibt sich schon den Lillien, genau wie er es davor in Braunschweig getan hat, mit Haut und Haaren. Das kaufe ich ihm schon ab. Er weiß auch erstaunlich viel schon über den Verein. Also ich glaube, er hat ihn auch immer schon wohlwollend mitverfolgt, weil er aus solchen Traditionsverein, mag jetzt ein Klischee sein, aber doch auch eine gewisse Kraft zieht. Also er sagt, wenn eine Stadt der Größe von Darmstadt, die jetzt keine Metropole ist, aber einfach eine ordentliche Stadt mit einer ordentlichen Größe, wenn die es schafft, Fanverein und Spieler zu einer Einheit zu verschmelzen, dann geht was. Wenn Ruhe im Verein ist, dann geht was. Und er hat auch seine Zeit bei seinem Trainerlehrgang, hat er mir dann gesagt, eine Abschlussarbeit geschrieben über das Umfeld von Fans in einem Traditionsverein und den Erwartungen, die an den Traditionsverein dann von außen herangetragen werden und wie man damit am besten umgeht. Also sprich, er ist jemand, der sehr reflektiert ist, der auch über den Tellerrand herausblickt und hinausblickt und ich glaube, der eine sehr gute Ansprache an die Spieler hat. Also deshalb setze ich große Erwartungen in Thorsten Liebuknecht und wünsche ihm sehr, dass er den bislang doch, finde ich, guten Weg weiterverfolgen kann. Und er hat es auch als einer der ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz wenigen Lillientrainer geschafft, auch mal einen U19-Spieler einzubauen in den ersten 4-5 Spielen. Den Clemens Riegel, der dann auch prompt jetzt für die EU-Nationalmannschaft nominiert wurde. Also sowas kannten wir gar nicht. Da wurde aus der Not heraus etwas geboren, was durchaus im Laufe der Saison wieder mal in Frage kommen kann. Und die Mannschaft wirkt in sich gefestigter als jetzt lange Zeit der letzten Saison. Also da gab es durchaus Verlegenheiten, wie wir sie jetzt auch von Bremen Sandhausen gesehen haben, die gibt es in der Form nicht. Also die Mannschaft wirkt deutlich stabiler und homogener, vielleicht in gewissen Teilen.
Hm, das ist alles sehr überraschend, oder was heißt, nee, nicht alles komplett überraschend. Aber ich habe sehr viel Skepsis gegenüber Lieberknecht wahrgenommen vor oder nach Bekanntgabe des Weckses, aber gar nicht so sehr bei Darmstadt-Fans, sondern ich habe das in anderen Podcasts gehört, dass man gerade eben aufgrund der Erfahrungen, die man bei ihm gesehen hat, was dann in der Endphase in Braunschweig zum Beispiel passiert ist, da dann doch eher kritisch ihm gegenüber stand. Jetzt hast du, finde ich, ganz gut Dinge beschrieben, die man aber auch schon so erahnen konnte, also das eben lieber Knecht jemand ist, der guteren ist, das Umfeld mitzunehmen, für eine gewisse Ruhe zu sorgen und nennen wir es jetzt einfach mal Wagenburg-Mentalität, aber zumindest so ein gemeinsames Ziel zu formen innerhalb der Mannschaft. Wie sieht denn jetzt der Fußball aus, den man spielt? Also zweitbeste Offensive der Liga, allerdings haut da natürlich auch so ein 6 zu 0 ordentlich rein, deswegen darf man das jetzt vielleicht auch nicht überbewerten, die bloße Zahl, was für einen Fußballlester spielen.
Vielleicht noch ein Wort zu Wagenburg-Mentalität. Ich glaube aber, dass er Darmstadt tatsächlich nicht kleiner macht, als es sind. Also er sagt jetzt nicht, wir sind hier die kleinste Wurst in der Theke, wie es gerne mal zu Erstliga-Zeiten unser Präsident gesagt hat, sondern er glaubt, oder ich glaube, er weiß schon, dass Darmstadt jetzt nicht mehr zu den kleinen Clubs der Liga gehört, sondern zu den Clubs der Liga, die durchaus auch mal den Blick nach vorne richten können. Aufstieg, glaube ich, von dem redet keiner, aber zumindest, dass wir hier doch eine ordentliche Rolle spielen. Und was für ein Fußball wir spielen. Es ist ein Fußball, der jetzt nicht so sehr auf Ballbesitz angelegt ist, aber es ist längst kein Hoch- und Weitfußball mehr, wie wir ihn lange Zeit sahen und dann später auch noch nicht mehr ganz so recht zugeschrieben bekommen haben, sondern es ist ein für mich sehr rationaler Fußball, der aber auch von schon emotionalen Momenten lebt. Also so jemand wie Philipp Tietz ist jemand, der sehr viel investiert, der auch eine gewisse Körperlichkeit mitbringt, aber auf sich nicht zu schade ist, im Vollsprint nach hinten mitzugehen und dennoch auch vorne die Ruhe hat dann zu verenden. Luca Pfeiffer, auch ein fast schon irritierend guter Stürmer für seine Körpergröße mit einer starken Ballbehandlung und Technik. Also da haben sich einfach jetzt viele losenden in sehr kurzer Zeit zusammengefunden. Auch die Innenverteidigung ist jetzt für den Moment mit Isherwood und mit Patrick Pfeiffer eingespielt, aber es gab immer wieder Wechsel, ohne dass da ein Substanzverlust da war und man hat es auch verstanden, den Abgang von Pahlson gut zu kompensieren mit im Moment einer Doppel-Sechs, Schnellhart und Kempeth, den man jetzt per se nicht zuschreiben würden, dass die Defensive aber ihre Stärke ist. Aber die stellen im Moment die Mittelfeldspieler vor der Abfahrt da und deshalb ist im Moment der Ball wird gut laufen gelassen, man versteht es auch schnell auf Rückstände zu reagieren oder immer mal ein Tor zu schießen. Jetzt diese von dir angesprochenen 25 Tore, fielen ja quasi erst in den letzten neun Spielen und da waren drei Kanzlersiege dabei, kann man sagen. Also die Mannschaft ist auch im Stande, sich zu belohnen für ihren Aufwand, ohne dass es jetzt zufällig ist. Ich glaube, da wächst ordentlich was zusammen. Aber ich bin auch gespannt, was Lozak, weil er hat ja auch immer ein feines Gespür und einen guten Blick für spielerische Entwicklungen.
Ja, ich muss mich ja gerade für meine Kolumne, die am Donnerstag rauskommt, mit Darmstadt beschäftigen, weil Darmstadt und Nürnberg am Freitag gegeneinander spielen und ich den Gegner immer vorstellen darf. Und ja, ich finde es ganz spannend, weil ich mich dann auch so ein bisschen mit Aussagen von Thorsten Lieberg befasst, der dann meinte, er musste so ein paar Automatismen wieder austreiben. Und als ich das darüber geschrieben habe, nämlich dieses flache Aufbauen aus der Abwehr, fiel in dem Moment das Tor bei Bremen gegen Sandhausen. Also es war dann sehr lustig, weil es genau der Moment war, wo es mich noch mal dran erinnert hat. Also ich finde das ganz interessant, dass er sagt, ja, man muss so paar Strukturen wieder aufbrechen, die, obwohl Markus Anfang nur ein Jahr da war und obwohl dann durchaus Veränderungen im Kader waren, dass man trotzdem damit sich befassen muss. Ich finde das interessant. Das merkt man, finde ich, auch, wenn man sich die Spiele anschaut. Also es gibt jetzt kein Verbot mehr, den Ball hinten rauszuhauen, sondern man darf das auch mal tun. Man tut es dann auch sehr präzise. Das finde ich auch ganz spannend. Also es gibt keinen Zweitligisten, dessen lange Pässe eine bessere Passquote haben. Also da ist dann durchaus auch was da. Und die angesprochenen beiden Offensiven sind natürlich ein Pfund und sind natürlich auch sehr, sehr spannend, weil die auch gut miteinander harmonieren und halt auch voneinander leben. Und das ist was, was ich, was man ja bei Sturmdus, gerade also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel zum FCN kommen, noch nicht immer so hat. Da wird viel vorne experimentiert, wen man denn jetzt da einsetzt. Aber die zwei, die funktionieren ziemlich, ziemlich gut miteinander. Das ist das eine und das andere. Ich finde schon auch so, ich meine, Kempe ist ja auch jemand, den ich in Nürnberg um aller Jahr erlebt habe. Und ich finde, der Kempe, der da ein Jahr in Nürnberg gespielt hat, mit dem Kempe in Darmstadt nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu tun, weil der in Darmstadt schon irgendwie, wahrscheinlich liegt es dran, dass er sich wohlfühlt oder sonst irgendwas. Aber der ist ja doch sehr gefährlich, in dem wir aufbaut, also sowohl außen im Spiel heraus als auch mit seinen Standards.
Das passt tatsächlich noch zu zwei Zahlen, dass Darmstadt außen im Spiel heraus jetzt schon 16 Tore geschossen hat. Das wäre Rang 3 in der Tabelle und nach Standards 6, das wäre Rang 2. Also in beiden Parametern durchaus gefährlich und vielleicht dann auch ein bisschen schlechter auszurechnen für den Gegner. Und wenige Flanken, also die zwei.
Ja, das ist mir auch aufgefallen beim Vorbereiten, dass es so Darmstadt die Mannschaft mit den wenigsten überhaupt ist. Das müsste Max ja gefallen.
So grundsätzlich, generell habe ich ja nichts gegen jede Flanke, aber manche Flanken sind mir so ein bisschen suspekt. Schlecht vorbereitete Flanken. Welche Rolle spielen denn dann noch Spieler im Kader, wie eben zum Beispiel Fabian Holland, der ja einer derjenigen ist, der jetzt am längsten mit dabei ist zur Saison 2015, 2016 gekommen ist, ja auch der Kapitän. Denn es braucht ja auch so ein bisschen ein Gerüst und du hast jetzt glaube ich die spielerisch wichtigen Spieler schon genannt. Ist er dann derjenige, der das Ganze zusammenhält? Wie sieht da die Kaderstruktur aus?
Das ist auch sehr interessant. Also er ist jetzt glaube ich langsam in den Top 10 der Spieler angekommen bei Darmstadt, die die meisten Spiele haben. Und er spielt ja linker Verteidiger, aber als ich dann ein paar Spiele, also die Spiele miterlebt habe, habe ich mich an einen Ausspruch auch von Thorsten Lieberknecht erinnert aus dem Interview, als er meinte, er stellt Spieler auch schon mal gerne ein bisschen unorthodox auf und Fabian Holland hat diese Saison auch schon phasenweise linkes Mittelfeld gespielt und findet sich, obwohl er linker Verteidiger ist, wie jetzt auch in Kiel, phasenweise im Zentrum vom 16er. Hält er sich da auf und er kriegt enorme Freiheiten und nutzt ja auch besser als bislang, wahrscheinlich weil dann doch Trainer wie Dirk Schuster oder auch Dimitrius Kamazou gesagt haben, du hältst deine Seite und ziehst zu, dass da nichts passiert. Aber er hat für meine Begriffe schon auch deutlich zugelegt, was das Spielverständnis anbetrifft. Auch die Ballverarbeitung, der ist schon fast ein universell einsetzbarer Linksverteidiger geworden, das sich auch mit Karic gut ergänzt. Die bilden so eine linke Flanke. Karic wurde aus Österreich verpflichtet und sollte eigentlich so das Backup für Hollands sein, aber mittlerweile spielen sie oft genug zeitgleich und der eine dann vorgezogen, der andere hinten dran. Also Holland kann mittlerweile sehr viel ausüben auf dem Platz und bietet eine enorme Konstante auf alle Fälle. Und er mit Campes sind tatsächlich so die letzten überbleibenden der Erstliga-Phase und bilden dahingehend sicherlich innerhalb der Mannschaft schon auch die Platzhirsche.
Sollte er noch alle 23 Spiele machen, dann würde er in der Rangliste der Rekordspieler bis auf Rang 6 klettern und folgende Menschen überholen. Wilhelm Huxhorn, Freddy Hess, Gerhard Kleppinger und Raphael Sanches.
Wir sind in den 80ern angekommen. Wilhelm Huxhorn war Keeper und hat sogar gegen Fortuna Köln mal einen direkten Abstoß.
Nicht schlecht.
Kleppinger ist doch Trainer für den Sandhausen, oder?
Genau, der wurde ja mit Kolowitz jetzt abgelöst, aber ist nach wie vor ein Sandhausen. Er ist auch hier in Darmstadt ein Spieler oder eine ehemalige Lilie mit einem guten Klang. Hat auch Darmstadt den schlechten Zeiten an der Seitenlinie gecoacht.
Einen Thema möchte ich mit dir noch kurz besprechen, bevor wir dann auf den 1. FC Nürnberg mal ausführlicher blicken. Und zwar war ja das Bölle, das Stadion am Böllenfalttor immer ein großes Thema. Wegen seines Charms, aber auch wegen seiner Restaurationsbedürftigkeit, wegen die DFL-Auflagen. Jetzt ist da endlich Bewegung reingekommen und ich hatte immer den Eindruck, auch schon in der Erstligasaison, in der das Thema halt am medial lautesten verhandelt wurde in Deutschland, dass es so eine zwiespaltene Beziehung der Fans zu diesem Umbau gab. Weil man einerseits, also mal abgesehen von irgendwelchen Gängelungen durch die DFL, dass man ein Dach brauchen würde und so weiter, weil ja mit diesem Stadion auch viel der erfolgreichen Zeiten verknüpft sind. Und ich hatte immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl, es gäbe die Angst, da könne man was verlieren, wenn es jetzt dann doch eben ein in Anführungszeichen normales Fußballstadion werden würde. Wie ist denn da der Stand?
Das Stadion hat jetzt tatsächlich einen grundlegenden anderen Charakter eingenommen. Also die Gegenerate ist eine zweirangige, ausgewachsene Gegenerate geworden. Hinter den Toren stehen solche Stahlrohrkonstruktionen, die da auch stehen bleiben werden. Und die Haupttribüne nimmt Gestalt an. Die wird dann nach dieser Saison auch bezogen werden können. Und damit ist das Böllnfalltor sicherlich nicht mehr zu erkennen. Die Leute, die es noch zu Erstliga-Zeiten kennengelernt haben. Ja, es war ein großes Thema in Darmstadt. Ich glaube, viele, viele Fans sind sehr, sehr froh, dass der Standort erhalten blieb, weil das waren auch Abwanderungsgedanken durchgespielt worden. Die kamen dann aus diversen Gründen nicht zustande. Und jetzt sind wir nach wie vor am Böllnfalltor und in diesem Jahr seit 100 Jahren. Also das ist schon ein sehr, sehr traditioneller Ground und das ist es schon wert, da zu bleiben. Und jetzt mit verändertem Gesicht, aber auch, ich habe den Eindruck, die Fans nehmen den Umbau gut an. Also es ist doch nochmal von der Lautstärke was anderes, wenn du einfach ein Dach über dir hast als zuvor. Und ich mache da durchaus ein klein wenig Wehenmut, aber auch enorme Vorfreude fest, wie das Stadion dann schlussendlich mal Gestalt annehmen wird. Wir haben ja auch noch so ein paar Marotten, wie die Dugena Uhr, die in den 70er Jahren erstellt wurde oder errichtet wurde, die schon seit wahrscheinlich in Betriebnahme nicht geht. Aber sie wird ihr Revival erleben in einer Ecke des Stadions, weil die Ecken bleiben offen. Das hat dann so einen englischen Charme. Das war auch ein Fan-Wunsch. Und diese Dugena Uhr, also ein alteingesessenes Darmstädteunternehmen, das es in Darmstädten längst nicht mehr gibt, die wird sich wiederfinden. Und wer in Zukunft oder spätestens nächste Saison ein Spiel am Böllnfall vorsieht, der dürfte sie in einer Ecke erspähen.
Sehr gut. Es gab ja auch tatsächlich erst eine Heimniederlage in der Heimtabelle auf Rang 4. Vier Siege bei 14 zu drei Toren und eben nur diese eine Niederlage. Also da scheint noch was vom Mythos geblieben zu sein, vom Bölle.
Genau, das erste Spiel, das war die Niederlage. Corona um Toast mit 0 zu 2 gegen Regensburg. Da konnte man schon erahnen, wo die Reise hingeht für Regensburg. Also nicht wirklich, aber schau, wo wir auch an der Stelle, dass die sich so da oben festsetzen.
Wisst ihr denn, wer auf Rang 3 der Heimtabelle liegt? Ich höre es klicken im Hintergrund, das zählt nicht. Der erste FC Nürnberg.
Ja, wenn du so fragst, muss es ja der Klub sein.
Genau, der ist tatsächlich zu Hause noch ungeschlagen, gemeinsam mit dem HSV Jan Regensburg und dem FC St. Pauli vor allem, der alle seine 6 Heimspiele gewinnen konnte. Die Mannschaft, die eben zu Hause noch nicht verlieren konnte. Das ist das nächste Team, über das wir sprechen wollen. Der Klub liegt auch in der Tabelle generell auf Rang 4. 21 Punkte. Das heißt, man ist direkt dran an Schalke und Regensburg mit 22 Punkten. Und auch St. Pauli mit 25 Punkten ist nicht so weit entfernt. Flo, was läuft gerade gut beim Klub, dass man so gut in der Tabelle dasteht?
Man kann einfach nicht verlieren, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Moment mal, wir sprechen vom 1. FC Nürnberg.
Wir sprechen vom 1. FC Nürnberg. Er hat jetzt die Saison übergreifend, die letzten 13 Spiele nicht verloren. Und wenn man dann noch ein bisschen 9 Spiele oben draufsetzt, dann sind es 22, in denen genau einmal verloren worden ist, nämlich gegen den HLV am Ende der letzten Saison. Es ist ein ungewohntes Gefühl in Nürnberg, dass man so wenig Spiele verliert. Man wartet eigentlich immer auf den Hammer, dass der mal kommt, aber er kommt nicht. Und es ist tatsächlich so, die Mannschaft ist wahnsinnig schwer zu schlagen. Das ist jetzt nicht nur an den Nullen Niederlagen festzumachen, sondern auch generell. Sie verteidigt so, das sieht man ja dann auch, wenn man auf die Gegentore geht. Sieben Gegentore ist nicht viel in elf Spielen, also insgesamt. Und das Interessante ist, diese sieben Gegentore sind dann auch in vier Spielen gefallen und in den anderen sieben gab es gar nicht. Also sieben Mal zu Null schon. Das ist nach elf Spieltagen auch der Wahnsinn. Letztes Jahr waren es, glaube ich, sechs in der ganzen Saison, wo man zu Null gespielt hat. Also man hat da für sich so eine Formation auch gefunden mit der Raute im Mittelfeld, die dann mit relativ aggressiven Spielern auf den Außen mit oder auf den Achtern mit Tempelmann und Kraus, die den Johannes Geiss, der auf der Sechs steht, ein bisschen unterstützen, weil Johannes Geiss jetzt nicht unbedingt so als defensiver Sechser bekannt ist. Und die zusammen und dann kommt im Zentrum, im defensiven Zentrum, mit Christopher Schindler halt auch noch ein Transfer dazu, der einfach dieser Abwehrkette unglaublich viel Ruhe gibt, also mal Esker Sörensen, der da neben ihm spielt, ist quasi nicht wieder zu erkennen im Vergleich zu der Zeit, wo er neben Lukas Müll verteidigt hat. Plötzlich eine ganz andere Ruhe insgesamt. Und Schindler ist halt auch noch ein Verteidiger, der wahnsinnig viel rausköpft und viele Bälle abfängt und mit auch so eine innere Ruhe halt einfach hat, mit seiner Erfahrung aus England und aus der Zeit bei 60 in der zweiten Liga. Also er ist sicherlich auch ein Faktor. Also viel von dem, was da gut läuft, läuft schon über die Defensive. Also dass man halt einfach wenig zulässt, dann hat man natürlich in den entscheidenden Momenten, also das war ja am Wochenende auch wieder so, auch mal Glück, dass eben ein Ball am Pfosten geht. Dann Christian Martenia ist ziemlich gut drauf und hält auch mal Dinge, wo man denkt, das kann gar nicht sein, dass er den jetzt auch noch hält. Und von daher, also es spielt halt alles so ein bisschen eine Rolle und inzwischen hat die Mannschaft schon auch zusätzlich so ein gewisses Selbstverständnis entwickelt, so nach dem Motto, ja, jetzt kommt erst mal und versucht uns zu schlagen. Wir wissen selber, dass wir schwer zu bespielen sind, das merkt man auch, wenn man den Spielern spricht. Also das ist so, mit jedem Spiel ist das Gewachsen dieses Selbstverständnis. Und inzwischen sagen sie auch selber, ja, das macht schon nochmal was mit einem, wenn man sich hinstellen kann und sagen kann, ja, wir sind ungeschlagen. Also Schindler hat das auch vom Spiel in Hamburg erzählt, wo sie vor dem Spiel sich nochmal darauf eingeschworen haben und gesagt haben, uns schlägt keiner. Und es war dann in Hamburg tatsächlich auch so.
Zwei zu zwei ging dieses Spiel aus. Liegt schon ein bisschen zurück. Also wir halten fest, wenn man nicht am Vormittag um 11 Uhr gegen Nürnberg spielt, dann ist es sehr schwer, Tore zu erzielen.
Die nehmen sich die Niederlagen immer in den Testspielen, weil es gab vorher noch ein anderes Testspiel in der Länderspielpause davor. Da hat man gegen Stuttgart auch 3-0 verloren. Und das war auch ganz katastrophal. Also da ging wirklich gar nichts, vor allem in der Offensive. Und von daher ist es dann schon interessant zu sehen, wie sie sich ihre Niederlagen immer dann nehmen, wenn die Spannung ein bisschen abfällt. Also da muss man dann, glaube ich, schon tatsächlich so ein bisschen an Psychologie glauben.
Und dann hast du ja schon einen anderen Fakt vorhin schon erwähnt. Wir kommen von der Mannschaft, dem SV Darmstadt 98, mit je zwei Spielern, die acht Tore gemacht haben. Und jetzt reden wir über den 1. FC Nürnberg, wo es keinen Spieler gibt, der aktuell in der Liga mehr als drei Tore erzielt hat. Die Tore verteilen sich sehr gleichmäßig über viele einzelne Spieler. Kann man jetzt positiv deuten? Kann man aber natürlich auch ein Problem drin erkennen wollen? Wozu neigst du?
Ich denke, es zeigt schon so ein bisschen den gesamtmannschaftlichen Ansatz, dass jeder in der Lage ist, so ein Ding zu machen. Also von Enrico Valentini bis Eric Schurranoch vorne drin. Aber es zeigt natürlich auch, dass noch so jemand fehlt. Das hat man ja letztes Jahr so ein bisschen gehabt mit Manuel Scheffler, der vorne drin war, der relativ viele Tore gemacht hat. Das ist aber jetzt eben ein bisschen mehr verteilt, auch weil man eben im Sturm so die Minuten etwas mehr verteilt oder verteilt hat. Und dann im Sturm jetzt momentan auf Schurranoch und Dovedan weitgehend setzt, wo man sagt, mit Dovedan ist auch ein Spieler, der sich ein bisschen mehr fallen lässt, der nicht so in Tornähe spielt. Von daher, es ist ja, ich würde schon sagen, dass das noch so fehlt, um so ganz vorne reinzukommen. Es liegt auch ein bisschen halt dran, dass nur, wenn Mats Möller-Deli keine Ideen hat, dann werden die Stürmer vorne halt gar nicht gefüttert. Und von daher, da geht schon noch mehr nach oben. Ich meine, man sieht es ja auch, 16 geschossene Tore ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
Und wie, würdest du sagen, hat sich der Spielstil von Robert Klaus verändert? Also, Dovedan sagt all denjenigen etwas, die vielleicht seinen zu Meme gewordenen PK-Ausschnitt gesehen haben. Da war Dovedan nämlich derjenige, der über den Ballfahren Zehner, glaube ich, verlagern sollte, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere. Aber ohne jetzt quasi diese alte Debatte noch mal aufbrechen zu wollen. Aber da ist er, glaube ich, vielen zum ersten Mal über den Weg gelaufen, als ein moderner Trainer mit eigenem, sehr taktisch geprägten Vokabular. Ihm zur Seite steht er mit Dieter Hecking als Sportdirektor, jemand, der sehr sehr viel Erfahrung mitbringt, auch auf der Trainerbank ganz lange gesessen ist. Welche Entwicklung hat denn auch Robert Klaus als Trainer und mit ihm dann die Mannschaft genommen?
Den ballfernen Zehner gibt es nicht mehr. Weil das war noch die Zeit, wo man mit 4-2-2-2 gespielt hat, tatsächlich so Flügelzehner hatte, so im alten RB-Stil. Und das hat er dann eben irgendwann aus dem Fenster geworfen und hat ganz klassisch auf eine Raute gesetzt. Und die funktioniert unglaublich gut. Das liegt natürlich am angesprochenen Mats Möller-Deli, der einer der wenigen natürlichen Zehner ist, die die 2. Liga so hat. Zum anderen aber eben auch an diesen beiden schon erwähnten Achtern. Also momentan ist das Lino Tempelmann. Das war letztes Jahr noch Fabian Nürnberger. Und auf der anderen Seite eben Tom Kraus, der noch mal einen wahnsinnigen Schritt gemacht hat. Der Leihgabe von RB Leipzig, der im nächsten Sommer dann normalerweise wieder weg sein dürfte. Der halt sehr aggressiv auch in die Zweikämpfe geht, aber trotzdem eine Dynamik nach vorne hat. Also er hat quasi gemerkt, wie er umstellen muss, dass er auch, um eben die Defensive zu stärken, das Zentrum mehr stärken muss, das Spiel des Gegners bisschen mehr auf die Außen lenken. Jetzt sind wir wieder bei den Flanken. Also Flanken sind halt in der Regel etwas ungefährlicher. Also Flanken dürfen die Gegner eher, sie sollen halt nicht durchs Zentrum kommen. Das erreicht man mit einer Route natürlich sehr viel besser. Also diese Umstellung, denke ich, ist schon auch was, wo ich sage, da hat er gelernt, also da ist auch ein bisschen weg. Es ist auch so vom, es ist immer noch in der Offensive, was viel über Tempo und Umschalten geht. Also wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt an das 2-0 vom Wochenende denkt, das ist schon so ein prototypisches Tor, wo einfach der Ball schnell getrieben wird übers Feld und dann sucht man den Abschluss. Das ist schon noch da, aber er hat sich insgesamt schon adaptiert in seiner Spielweise. Er kam mit einem sehr prototypischen RB-Ansatz, also der wirklich das sah wie Reisbrett-RB-Dosenfabrik Maschinenfußball aus. Und er hat aber adaptiert und gelernt. Und inzwischen ist es eben ein Fußball, der für den Kader und für die Mannschaft sehr gut passt. Man hat dann auch wirklich, finde ich, punktuell noch mal im Sommer die Leute geholt, wo man halt was gebraucht hat. Man hat auch sich von verdienten Spielern getrennt mit Markreiter, mit Mühlen, mit Behrens, also die ja doch auf eine ordentliche Summe in ein Spiel gekommen sind. Aber deren Zeit halt dann irgendwie, man hat gesagt, ja, man muss jetzt halt da auch mal einen Cut machen und hat dann auch, also eben für die Innenverteidigung, da war ich selber auch skeptisch, dass man für die Innenverteidigung zwei Spieler über 30 holt. Bei Christopher Schindler war die Skepsis absolut unbegründet. Das habe ich schon erwähnt. Bei Flo Hübner sieht es ein bisschen anders aus. Der galt ja schon immer als verletzungsanfällig, hat sich dann früh verletzt, noch vor der Saison in einem Testspiel, weil Sascha Mölders ihn an der Schulter gezogen und nach unten geworfen hat. Also seitdem hat er Probleme mit der Schulter und hat also nur zwei Spiele gemacht und fällt seitdem aus. Aber man hat eben gesehen, man muss da in der Defensive im Zentrum was machen. Man hat mit Tempelmann und Dumann noch mal fürs zentrale Mittelfeld auch Leute geholt, die so ein bisschen mehr diesen Rautenfußball spielen können. Und von daher, das war dann schon sehr entscheidend. Und Dieter Hecking hat natürlich auch seinen Anteil daran, dass Robert Klaus überhaupt noch da ist. Weil ich glaube, in dem Januar letztes Jahr waren ordentlich Probleme. Und da hätte das Umfeld auch durchaus in typischer Nürnberger Art kippen können. Aber es tat es nicht. Und das lag schon auch daran, dass Dieter Hecking da sehr moderierend eingegriffen hat.
Ich habe schon gehört, Matthias hat sich im Muted. Wolltest du eine Frage stellen?
Nee, aber ich denke, Flor hat es natürlich perfekt als hautnahe Beobachter aufgedröselt. Ich finde auch, dass Nürnberg einfach im Moment einen guten Flow hat. Also diese Defensive, ich glaube, die stellt sich ja fast schon von selbst auf. Nicht weil keine Alternativen da wären, sondern weil sie einfach so eingespielt und so sicher ist, die Viererer Kette und diese jungen Wilden nach vorne raus. Wie du gesagt hast, Tom Kraus oder auch der Erich Schuranoff, ist ja auch schön zu sehen, wenn da so frisches Blut reinkommt, das dann auch verfängt. Oder Lino Tempelmann, was andere Vereine auch durch Freiburg im Moment abbekommen. Das heißt Regensburg mit Bukalfa. Ja, das ist schon wirklich bemerkenswert. Und Chapeau, also ich bin gespannt, wie es dann am Wochenende sich darstellt, wenn unsere beiden Clubs aufeinandertreffen. Nürnberg bekommt halt auch kaum ein Tor aus dem Spiel raus. Wenig verwunderlich, wenn man siebenmal zu null spielt. Aber ich glaube, da dürften sie führend sein in der Rangliste. Das ist einfach im Moment gewachsen, wie du sagst auch am Anfang. Da hat man jetzt so das Bewusstsein, naja, guckt ihr mal, wie er zum Ziel kommt. Wir wissen im Moment, wie es geht. Oder wie wir es verhindern.
Flo, das hört sich alles nach einer Geschichte an, wo es auch sehr gut sein könnte, dass wir in 23 Spieltagen miteinander sprechen und Nürnberg total stabil aufgestiegen ist. Und man sagt, ja, wir waren jetzt einfach ruhig, wir haben gute Transfers gemacht, wir haben uns punktuell gut verstärkt. Und es war halt schlau, an Klaus festzuhalten, denn der hat den nächsten Entwicklungsschritt genommen. Du darfst natürlich noch nicht so weit denken, denn du guckst da ja auch ein bisschen emotionaler drauf, trotz deiner Rolle als Journalist. Aber das wirkt doch alles schon sehr gefestigt und eben doch anders, als man den Club erlebt hat jetzt über viele Jahre hinweg.
Ja, es ist schon interessant zu sehen, dass es, es gibt ja so ein bisschen Parallelen zu der Relegations-Saison, und da Rene Weiler sehe ich schon auch, da hat man auch, da hat man glaube ich am Ende 17 Spiele in Folge nicht verloren, auch nach vorne, ja nicht so, man hatte damit natürlich mit Völkruck und Burgstaller auch nochmal andere Stürmer, aber es war jetzt kein, es war jetzt nicht der mega attraktive Fußball, aber es war ein sehr solider Fußball, man hat relativ viel wegverteidigt, also die Parallelen sehe ich schon, ich sehe aber auch, wenn man sich die unterliegenden Zahlen halt mal anguckt, dass man jetzt schon sowohl bei den Expected Goals als auch bei den Expected Points an den Punkt ist, wo man vielleicht auch ein bisschen Regression zur Mitte erwarten muss, weil man momentan Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich in der Hand drüber ist, also so ein bisschen noch, sagen, Ball flach halten, aber natürlich kann sich da auch so ein bisschen, ja, ein Flow entwickeln in der Hinsicht. Also ich möcht's, ich hab's vor der Saison eigentlich relativ klar ausgeschlossen, da war ja das Ziel. Platz 5 bis 8 war vorgegeben und 5 bis 8 hielt ich dann auch für realistisch und alles drüber, hielt ich ein bisschen für Träumerei inzwischen, wenn ich das sehe. Auch natürlich im Hinblick auf die anderen Mannschaften, die es da so gibt und die sich ja teilweise doch auch schwer tun. Und dann ist da vorne mit Regensburg auch noch eine Mannschaft, wo man ja eigentlich jede Woche darauf wartet, dass sie einbrechen und sie tun's aber nicht. Also natürlich hat man dann irgendwann so die bisschen, das ist die Hoffnung als Fan und ja, dass es vielleicht mehr würde, aber ich trau mich noch nicht so recht da, da dran zu glauben.
Ja, ich mein, da ist ja auch der Rahmen durchaus wichtig. Also der Hinweis auf die Relegations-Saison, das war 2015-16 mit René Weiler, der ist ja richtig, denn da hatte man ja unter anderem mit dem SC Freiburg und Rasenball-Sport zwei sehr starke Mannschaften, die eben Platz 1 und 2 unter sich ausgemacht haben, auch wenn da zwischenzeitlich Nürnberg mitspielen konnte. Und dann Relegation ist halt schwierig. Das war damals gegen Eintracht Frankfurt und wir alle wissen, wie es ausgegangen ist. Der 1. FC Nürnberg ist eben nicht aufgestiegen. Glaubst du, dass Dieter Hecking der Schlüssel dazu sein könnte, dass sich jetzt langfristig etwas in der Kultur dieses Vereins ändert? Denn wenn ich mir die finanziellen Kennzahlen zum Beispiel angucke, dann ist der Club inzwischen einfach ein etablierter Zweitligist, aber gar nicht in dem besten Sinne, sondern man liegt eigentlich in fast allen Kennziffern irgendwo auf Rang 24 unter den ersten 38 Vereinen des deutschen Profifußballs. Das heißt, man ist halt einfach ein Zweitligist. Das ist jetzt auch keine Neuigkeit. Aber so ein bisschen hat man da halt auch jetzt über viele Jahre hinweg eine Regression gehabt, wenn man sich an die früheren Zeiten vom Club in der ersten Liga noch erinnert. Als man noch Fahrstuhlmannschaft war, inzwischen ist es kein Fahrstuhl mehr, man steht jetzt einfach im Untergeschoss.
Ja, also ich denke, Dieter Hegging ist schon die eine Komponente, der vielleicht auch so ein bisschen Kontinuität auf der Position wieder reinbringt, weil man doch relativ viel Wechsel in den letzten Jahren hatte, mit erst von Bornemann auf Palikutia und dann von nach nur im knappen Jahr von Palikutia dann auf Hegging, also dass da ein bisschen Ruhe auf der Position reinkommt, weil ein Vorstand ja eigentlich keine Position sein sollte, wo so wahnsinnig viel Rotation oder Wechsel drin ist. Das andere ist aber durchaus auch der Vorstandspartner mit Nils Rosso, der eben ganz anderen Ansatz nochmal wählt, der eben sagt, wir müssen den Verein auch in der Stadt etablieren. Der ist in den Jahren vorher in der Stadt halt nicht so wahrgenommen worden. Es ist auch krass, wenn man mit potenziellen Sponsoren spricht, wie viel in der Zeit, gerade in der Spätphase von Martin Bader noch und dann auch in der frühen Phase von Michael Mieske, der dann ein bisschen da dagegen gearbeitet hat, wie viel Sponsoren verprellt worden sind einfach durch das Auftreten. Und man versucht das jetzt wieder durch so zivilgesellschaftliche Aktionen auch, also ganz viel. Ich bin ja im echten Leben jenseits des Journalisten auch noch Lehrer und nehme jedes Jahr auch mit meinen Klassen an dem Projekt gegen Antisemitismus vom FCN teil, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Teil der CSR-Maßnahmen des FCNs. Und da gibt es eben noch ganz viel andere, also es gibt eine Aktion, die nennt sich Spielräume. Da werden dann irgendwie Spielplätze wieder neu aufgebaut, das wird aufgeräumt. Der Raum von der Nürnberger Tafel ist renoviert worden mit Hilfe des FCN. Also man versucht so den Ansatz des Etablierens des Vereins in der Zivilgesellschaft auch noch mal, und ich glaube, das ist fast genauso wichtig, weil halt einfach die Stadt wieder mitgenommen werden will und auch muss, um ein bisschen davon wegzukommen, von dem, was gerade, da muss man in die Baderzeit zurückgehen, vor allem, was da viel kaputt gemacht worden ist, auch, dass man sich eben so ein bisschen da in der Hinsicht abgeschottet hat. Und das, finde ich, funktioniert ziemlich gut. Also man begegnet so dem FCN an ganz vielen Stellen im normalen Leben jetzt auch wieder. Also ich musste jetzt gerade einen Zettel von meiner Tochter unterschreiben, dass, wenn der FCN in der ersten Klasse zu Besuch kommt, dass sie fotografiert werden darf und auf die Homepage oder auf den Facebook auftritt, dass das Foto dann darf. Also man merkt es dann auch an so Kleinigkeiten, dass der FCN halt wieder versucht, mehr reinzukommen. Und das ist, denke ich, fast genauso wichtig wie der sportliche Teil, weil dann eben auch so der Verein an sich wieder mehr ins Bewusstsein der Leute kommt.
Ja, spannender Punkt. Der Klub war ja einer der ersten Vereine in der 2. Liga. Definitiv, ich glaube aber auch liegarbeit im deutschen Profifußball, der eben eine eigene CSR-Abteilung eingerichtet hat. Also Corporate Social Responsibility ist der Name zur Abkürzung. Das heißt, es geht eben einfach um die gesellschaftliche Verantwortung, die man als Verein hat. Das kann auch viel PR sein, aber du hast jetzt einige Aktionen genannt und da waren jetzt gar nicht alle Dinge mit dabei. Also man hat sich ja auch den ökologischen Schutz des Klimas auf die Fahnen geschrieben. Will jetzt hier nicht jede kleine Aktion hier nennen, aber das ist schon wirklich interessant, dass der Club da weiter ist als ganz viele andere Fußballvereine und meinem Blick von außen nach. Und das scheint es jetzt zu bestätigen, eben nicht nur, um sich selbst ein gutes Image zu geben, sondern eben, um viele Dinge im Kleinen zu bewegen, weil das eben auch positiv am Club haften bleibt und das macht was mit der Verwurzelung in der Region. Spannender Ansatz. Dann lasst uns noch über zwei weitere Vereine sprechen bei Regensburg. Da hat sich vom spielerischen her jetzt nicht so viel verändert. Deswegen wollen wir mal noch auf Schalke 04 und auf den FC St. Pauli gucken. Platz 3 und Platz 1 in der aktuellen Tabelle. Matthias, lass mal mit Schalke beginnen. Die kommen so langsam richtig ins Laufen. So macht es zumindest den Eindruck, haben sich immer mehr jetzt in diese zweite Liga reingebissen und liegen jetzt eben auf diesem dritten Tabellenplatz mit 22 Punkten. Konnten jetzt auch wieder gewinnen. Das war jetzt dann schon der vierte Sieg in Folge in der Liga. Was funktioniert denn gerade bei Schalke jenseits von Terode, was vorher noch nicht funktioniert hat?
Vielleicht war es ja mit der Torwartwechsel, dass Fermann raus rotierte und dafür Freisel rein. Freisel kennen wir noch aus Sandhäusner Zeiten. Ich habe den damals schon als sehr selbstbewussten und ehrgeizigen Vertreter seiner Zunft gemeint kennengelernt zu haben. Er ist schon einer, der, glaube ich, die Chance, die er jetzt bekommen hat, nur zu willig ergreift und er auch dann ein paar mal seine Flugkünste unter Beweis gestellt hat. Aber an und für sich, glaube ich, Schalke hatte lange genug Zeit, sich auf die zweite Liga vorzubereiten. Hat sich auch, finde ich, mit wichtigen Personalien da verstärkt und scheint jetzt im Moment einfach auch so gefestigt zu sein. Also das wurde nach dem Spiel gegen Dresden ja auch der Teamgedanke immer wieder heraufbeschworen und sie haben sich als Einheit dargestellt oder vorgestellt und da, glaube ich, mit den Ergebnissen wächst so ein gewisses Selbstverständnis heran. Und mich hat jetzt am Samstag eher Dresden überrascht in der Herangehensweise und in der Art, wie sie gespielt haben, zwar ohne jeglichen Ertrag, aber Schalke hat dann auch gewusst, okay, wir kriegen vielleicht noch mal eine Chance, dann machen wir einen Deckel drauf und so war es dann tatsächlich. Und gerade der Ovejan ist ja schon sehr auffällig, finde ich. Das war vielleicht ein nicht minder wichtiger Neuzugang. Also hat, glaube ich, bis langende im Liga-Vergleich die meisten, lass mich mal kurz gucken, bevor ich da Quatsch erzähle, die meisten Schlüsselpässe, die meisten Flanken und hat jetzt auch schon sechs Vorlagen mit den zwei vom Wochenende. Also der scheint ja auch die Situation mit Haut und Haaren anzunehmen in dem Club. Also lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, ich glaube, sie haben sich an den richtigen Stellen verstärkt. Wie gut an der 2. Anzug passt, mussten sie bislang noch nicht sonderlich austesten. Also mal gucken, wenn da Säulen wegbrechen. Latza war es jetzt zugegebenermaßen, wurde aber durch Pahlzon auch gut aufgefangen. Mal gucken, wenn sie richtig gefordert werden, ob da noch mal was ins Wangen gerät. Aber für den Moment wirkt es sehr in sich überzeugt, sehr ehrgeizig und im Vergleich zu Bremen, die wir vorhin besprochen hatten, erstmal auf dem richtigen Weg.
Auch auswärts sehr stabil. Der FC Schalke 04 in der Auswartstabelle Rang 2 mit vier Siegen und nur einer Niederlage bei 8 zu 4 Toren. Zuhause gab es ein bisschen mehr, auch für den Gegner zu holen. Das wurde ja auch gerade am Anfang der Saison. Hat man das ja auch medial gut mitbekommen, wie da die Schalke auch so manchen Punkt verloren haben zuhause. Flo, das scheint mir dann eine Mannschaft zu sein, wo wir, wenn wir gerade über Nürnberg gesprochen haben, mit sieben Gegentreffern. Schalke hat mit elf jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig mehr kassiert. Die sind einfach sehr stabil und wenn du vorne ja nicht nur ein Terrode hast, sondern Böte ist jetzt auch schon bei vier Treffern. Wenn du vorne eben dann in der Regel immer triffst, dann ist das ja auch schon eine gute Basis für eine sehr gute Zweitligasaison.
Ja, also ich denke die angesprochenen Punkte sind schon auch noch sind sind wirklich wichtig, also dass man halt einfach, man hatte auf Schalke ja eigentlich wirklich genug Zeit sich vorzubereiten auf die zweite Liga. Es war ja dann doch relativ früh klar, dass man absteigt und ich denke, das ist auch so der Unterschied zu Bremen. Also man hat halt da einfach schon an einem Kader in gewisser Weise bauen können, der dann Zweitliga relevant und tauglich ist. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ovej Harn heißt er. Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist wirklich ein absoluter Schlüsseltransfer, sehe ich genauso. Martin Freisel ist mir auch schon sehr oft in Sandhausen aufgefallen. Also das sind halt auch genauso so Geschichten, die mit rein spielen und dann eben zusätzlich auch noch. Ich denke, man hat am Anfang einfach gebraucht, weil naja, wenn man so viele Neuzugänge hat, dann müssen die halt auch erst zusammenfinden. Und jetzt läuft es. Und dann hat man eben doch einen Trainer, der die, aber da kann, muss ich gar nicht so viel sagen, da gibt es andere hier, die da mehr dazu sagen können, der halt einfach die zweite Liga kennt. Und das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt so der vom Ansatz her so der typische Absteiger-Dominanz-Auftritt, den man sich vorstellen könnte. Aber er funktioniert ja dann doch ganz gut.
Ja, liegt es vielleicht an Dimitrios Gramozis, Matthias, dass man eben gar nicht so spielt, wie der große Erstligaverein, der abgestiegen ist, sondern halt wie eine Zweitligamannschaft spielen muss, weil er halt auch die Erfahrung hat?
Ich glaube, dass Gramozis ein Trainer ist, der ein Team das spielen lässt, was es kann. Also, dass er jetzt auch keine überbauten Erwartungen an ein Team hat. Klar will er ein Team weiterentwickeln. Das hat er in Darmstadt geschafft, indem er ihn dann doch den eher destruktiveren Ansatz peu à peu ausgetrieben hat, ohne jetzt die defensive Stabilität zu verleugnen. Also, die war auch in Darmstadt unter ihm durchaus gegeben und ich glaube, im Moment, also es gab auch in Darmstadt damals ein paar Gerüchte, dass als er seinen Abgang klar war, dann nicht mehr der allergrößte Ehrgeiz am Stadt war, aber das kann auch einfach nur Gossip sein und muss nicht für wahre Münze genommen werden, aber er hat, von meinen Begriffen, in Darmstadt gute Arbeit geleistet. Es zeigt jetzt auch in Schalke, dass er die richtigen Stellschrauben findet und die jetzt nicht überdreht, sondern sorgsam justiert, so würde ich es jetzt mal von außen betrachtet bewerten. Ich glaube auch, dass Pahlson nach Schalke gegangen ist, war primär sein Verdienst. Also, die hatten sich schon zu Darmstädter Zeiten gut verstanden und das zeigt sich ja jetzt erneut, dass da sich schnell die entscheidenden Faktoren zusammengefunden haben und vielleicht noch ein Fun-Fact zu Freisel. Ich hatte mal, als er noch in Sandhausen war, vernommen, dass er wohl ein ehemaliger Skifahrer gewesen sei und habe jetzt im Vorfeld der Sendung nochmal recherchiert. Also er hat sich wohl selber mal als einer der Top 3 Junior-Skifahrer in Niederösterreich bezeichnet. Also er scheint auch da Qualitäten zu haben, nicht nur zwischen den Pfosten.
Na gut, da hat er ja also. Also er hat Erfahrung damit, wenn es steil berg abgeht und dann passt er natürlich auch zu einer Mannschaft, die abgestürzt ist wie Schalke 04.
Wobei Niederösterreich wahrscheinlich nicht so viele hohe Berge haben wird wie Tirol.
Das ist dann zwischen den Stangen muss er sich ja beim Skifahren auch sehr gut.
Gut, also das ist Schalke 04. Für die läuft es gerade sehr gut und dann haben wir über allen drohend den FC St. Pauli mit 25 Punkten nach elf Spieltagen und man schießt halt einfach sehr gerne Tore auf St. Pauli. Seit der letzten Aufnahme ist geschehen ein 3 zu 0 gegen Dynamo Dresden, ein 4 zu 2 in Heidenheim, ein 4 zu 0 gegen Hansa Rostock. Wobei, wobei, Flo, da könnte man jetzt natürlich auch ein bisschen die umgedrehte Dynamo Dresden-Diskussion führen, denn mit Rostock und Dresden sind da zwei Mannschaften mit dabei, wo die Spiele emotional sehr aufgeladen sind, die aber auch St. Pauli als etablierte Zweitlegermannschaft gewinnen muss. Wo liegt denn jetzt dann die Wahrheit in der aktuellen Dominanz bei St. Pauli? Wie gut sind die Hamburger?
Ich finde die so gut, wie die Tabelle sagt, aber mein Urteil muss ja nicht stimmen. Aber an sich finde ich schon, also ich finde die von allem dem, was man so sieht, schon am beeindruckendsten. Also da ist eine konstante offensive Produktion. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass die einfach nur, also um jetzt mal den FCN nochmal rauszunehmen, die haben am Wochenende auch vier Tore gemacht, aber ich glaube je nach Anbieter irgendwo zwischen 0,7 und 1,0 Expected Goals haben die halt vier Tore gemacht. Und wenn man sich dann mal anguckt, was St. Pauli hat, die konstant in den letzten Spielen immer auf zwei oder über zwei lagen und das eigentlich in sehr, sehr vielen der Spiele reproduzieren. Also von daher, da ist einfach sehr viel Qualität in der Offensive da. Auch da spielt man ja mit 4-4-2 mit Raute, hat da mit Thierry auch noch jemanden, der dann zusätzlich noch reingeht. Da ist einfach sehr, sehr viel offensive Qualität da und dann kommt dann eben noch dazu, mit Pacarada wahrscheinlich den besten Linksverteidiger der zweiten Liga zusätzlich noch, der auch ganz viel nach vorne anschiebt. Also es ist einfach, es macht sehr viel Spaß St. Pauli zuzuschauen und das kommt dann obendrein auch noch drauf zu den vielen Toren und zu der Dynamik. Klar sind immer, wir sind in der zweiten Liga, es gibt in jedem Spiel Momente, wo man sich denkt, naja, wenn das jetzt in die andere Richtung rutscht, dann könnte es auch anders aussehen, aber sie haben halt auch diese Konstanz-Stunt drin. Also kann mich jetzt eigentlich, ich glaube, gegen Paderborn war mal ein Spiel, das nicht so gut lief, aber ansonsten. Das ist eigentlich größtenteils richtig, richtig stark, wie die spielen und auftreten und dann halt auch durchaus auch mal durchtauschen können und relativ viel Kader-Tiefe haben und dann mit, und da blutet mir natürlich als Nürnberger jetzt das Herz, wenn man sieht, wie viele Ex-Nürnberger da spielen und das sind ja nicht nur, nicht nur Burgstaller und Ditken, wo man es weiß, sondern mit Jakov Medic und mit Nikola Vasili.
Mensch, gibt es da irgendeine Verbindung vom Club zu St. Pauli?
Ich überlege mit Andreas Bornemann als Sportvorstand oder Sportchef, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es in Hamburg heißt. Aber man merkt dann, es sind halt auch so Transfers wie eben Leute, die in Nürnberg U21 gespielt haben und die dann irgendwie über Umwege da gelandet sind. Aber Medic tut mir persönlich ganz, ganz besonders weh, weil ich begleite ja die U21 auch noch immer mit und das war wirklich einer der wenigen, wo man quasi fast mit dem ersten Ballkontakt hat. Das war gleich ein Pass aus der Tiefe in den Lauf des Angreifers, der dann das gleich vollendet hat. Also es war wirklich so mit dem ersten Moment einer, wo ich gesagt habe, der wird mal was. Und mich hat es dann auch geärgert, dass man den Weg gegangen ist, dass man ihn halt erst nach Wehen verliehen hat und dann war er ja zwei Jahre verliehen und Wehen hat dann irgendwann die Kaufoptionen gezogen und letztes Jahr war er ja dann irgendwie teilweise Zehner und und Stürmer bei Wehen, weil die so viele Ausfälle glaube ich hatten, dass er dann auch da gespielt hat und selbst das hat er gut gemacht. Also das ist denke ich schon so ein Schlüsseltransfer und Wasili ist auch ein sehr, sehr solider Torwart, der dann über sehr viele Umwege, ja der kam ja aus der Ukraine, dann bei St. Pauli gelandet ist. Aber da ist, da ist viel gut beim Einkaufen passiert. Also Andreas Bornemann hat halt seine Verbindungen spielen lassen. Er ist jetzt auch nicht derjenige, der wahnsinnig viel, also im Gegensatz zum Beispiel zu Darmstadt, ja jetzt viel auf Datenscouting und so weiter setzt. Also das ist ja ein Anse- oder auch Dieter Hecking macht das nicht. Also das ist ja eher noch so Netzwerken und wir schauen, wen wir kennen. Aber das hat er eben sehr, sehr gut gemacht.
Da war jetzt sehr viel Lob mit dabei. Matthias, was willst du ergänzen?
Also gefällt mir auch sehr gut. Gerade das Spiel haben wir ja noch vom Wochenende vor Augen, das 4-0 gegen Rostock. Das war ja phasenweise in den Rausch gespielt. Also wirklich Hut ab. Da geht einiges auf der Zeit. Thierry auch hervorragend. Spielt jetzt mittlerweile auch in der garnerischen Nationalmannschaft. Mit Burgstaller eine gute Kombi vorne drin. Mit Marcel Hartl haben sie sich jetzt fast noch die garantierte Aufstiegspersonalie geholt, der zuletzt mit Bielfeld und Union hochgegangen ist. Den muss man auch erst mal aneinander ziehen. Wenn wir uns aber zurück erinnern, also zu Beginn des Jahres, wir hatten ja eigentlich keine Winterpause durch die Corona-bedingte Späteansetzung der Saison. Da war St. Pauli, ich habe noch mal nachgeschaut, mit 9 Punkten auf Rang 17 und seither haben sie 64 Punkte geholt. Das ist schon wirklich ein unfassbarer Lauf, ohne dass man jetzt den Coach ausgetauscht hätte, Timo Schulz, ist jetzt in seine 2. Saison gegangen und scheint ja, warum auch immer, einen wahnsinnigen Turnaround herbeigeführt zu haben. Und das nötigt mir auch gehörigen Respekt ab. Also, wenn man auch betrachtet, dass so ein Personal wie Christoffer Abeworr seit einem Jahr schon verletzt ist und es fällt gar nicht auf, und er war ja schon einer der prägnanteren Innenverteidiger der 2. Liga. Auch das zeigt, dass St. Pauli sich enorm gefestigt und weiterentwickelt hat in den letzten Monaten. Das ist kein laues Lüftchen, das ist schon mit Substanz.
Und ja, auch die Abgänge gut kompensiert. Oma Mamouche ist ja da. Derjenige, den man jetzt auch in der 1. Liga sehen kann. Salazar zu Frankfurt und noch so manch anderer. Das interessante bei Timo Schulz, dadurch, dass es diese wunderbare Podcast-Dokumentation Being Timo Schulz von Millenton gibt, kann man ja ganz gut nachvollziehen, wie er auch diese turbulente letzte Saison gesehen hat, weil die haben über 20 Telefonate mit ihm geführt und daraus dann eben einen die Saison begleitenden, im Rückblick begleitenden Podcast gemacht. Das Interessante ist, alles, was er da gesagt hat, das scheint auch jetzt genau so zu kommen. Also er hat mit ihnen darüber gesprochen, wann er auf Defensive umgestellt hat. Er hat mit ihnen über Raute und Spielauslösung gesprochen und hat mit ihnen auch darüber gesprochen, wo es jetzt noch weitergehen muss, wo man besser werden muss. Nicht nur im Umschaltverhalten, sondern eben auch aus dem Ballbesitzer Rauslösung finden, eben diese Raute noch ein bisschen kreativer ausspielen. Und all die Dinge sind jetzt einfach passiert. Und das, obwohl eben wichtige Spieler gegangen sind, ist ja schön, wenn es auch mal so kommt, wenn das, was Trainer planen, doch auch mal umgesetzt wird. So grüßt dann der FC St. Pauli von der Tabellenspitze und ihm geht es sehr gut da oben. Ihr zwei, ich danke euch sehr. Das war eine lange, aber ich finde sehr interessante Aufnahme und das liegt ausschließlich an euch beiden. Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich euch mal wieder im Rasenfunk mit dabei hatte. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Florian Zenger. Folgt ihm auf Twitter, da ist er der atflo-zenger und ihr könnt natürlich ihn auch in diversen Publikationen verfolgen bei der Nürnberger Zeitung und den Nürnberger Nachrichten und bei Club Fans United und im KDEP Podcast. Flo, vielen Dank, dass du neben deinen ganzen 1000 Projekten zusätzlich zu deinem Lehrer-Job auch noch hier im Rasenfunk warst. Mir ebenso. Und ganz herzlichen Dank auch an Matthias Kneifl vom Hoch und Weit Podcast, der sich vielleicht jetzt umbenennen muss. Das habe ich mir vorhin gedacht, als du gesagt hast, ich spiele gar nicht mehr Hoch und Weit. Da dachte ich mir, was? Das ist ja Etikettenschwindel.
Wir bleiben uns treu. Zumindest vom Namen her.
Immerhin der Kickschuh-Blog kann noch so weiter so heißen, das stimmt. Als AtKickschuh-Blog kann man dir auch auf Twitter folgen, natürlich auch dem Podcast Hoch und Weit. Danke dir, Matthias, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Recht herzlichen Dank.
Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist werbepayable und sponsorunfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure Spenden. Wie ihr uns unterstützt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubund nicht nur wir profitieren davon, sondern auch unsere Gäste, die ein kleines Honorar bekommen für ihre Auftritte hier. In diesem Sinne, bitte unterstützt uns. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Und dann hören wir uns wieder in der nächsten Woche in der Schlusskonferenz und natürlich auch hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Bis dahin macht's gut.